it's june now and we all know what time
it is
time for one of the last few seasonal
previews for the upcoming summer 2021
season we just had a banger of a season
and i'm sure that everyone had their
feel of crazy shows representing all
kinds of genres
while we slowly bid the spring 2021
season goodbye
it's time to look to be on the horizon
of what's to come what i'll do for today
is to compile what i think are the top
10 most anticipated
new anime this upcoming summer season
the examples are done on an anecdotal
basis but i feel that it does a decent
job of representing what most people are
looking forward to hey if you're someone
who's not too updated with the shows to
come
maybe this is also your chance to pick
up something that you might actually
find interesting but before we begin
let me introduce you to today's sponsors
moonlight sculptor if the name sounds
familiar to you it's because the game
allows you to take part in the world of
the popular light novel and manoa
legendary moonlight sculptor let me tell
you from experience that among the many
novel adaptations i've played
few are as immersive as moonlight
sculptor enough to make me check out the
actual source material
this game is a chibi mmorpg that comes
with a plethora of features
a striking feature in this game is the
existence of sleep mode
as i say a true hero never rests so this
feature allows you to keep up with
farming loot and xp
even while offline moonlight sculptor
has had its first major update
giving us the treacherous miracan tower
to explore we also got a green day event
as well as guild hideouts for the more
adventurous types
new party dungeons and raids including a
chance at glory in the tyrant's ominous
temple
await i'll be leaving a link in the
description box so you can join the fun
feel free to also join moonlight
sculptures many communities they have a
discord server and a twitter where you
can get the latest news asap
and meet new friends along the way now
let's get on with the show
death game or battle royale anime seems
to be picking up steam now isn't it
after quite the drought we had both
glyph near and darwin's game last year
which i both maintain to be rather
underrated shows that you should
definitely check out but for this summer
season
we'll look to be seeing more in the form
of battle in five seconds after meeting
just like the
previous instances here we see our
protagonist akira to be one of the many
lucky people who gets whisked out of
their everyday life to be part of an
experiment
said experiment of course practically
erases them from existence while
granting them powers
powers that include the ability to
enhance one's own body
to being able to affect reality itself
there's quite a wide range of brokenness
if you ask me
now what do they do with it trials
one-on-one fights battle royales fights
to the death
everything is on the table in this one
armed with his most powerful asset
his intelligence akira looks to win this
game and unravel the secret behind the
sketchy organization
responsible for these fights
is back again with its new offering this
season aquatope of white sand tells the
story of kukuru an 18 year old girl who
works at an aquarium and her meeting
with runaway idol [ __ ] the two
eventually get to know each other but
those days together look to be coming to
an end due to a looming crisis with the
aquarium being in danger of closing down
the two look to get to know each other
and share their dreams
is it just me or does this show remind
you of a lull in the sea must be the
watery aesthetics i think based on the
synopsis alone though i'm seeing
something like a coming-of-age story
where the two girls get to grow with
each other in a bit to save the aquarium
in a way i can also see something like
adachi and shimamura from it either way
i think that quite a lot of people are
excited for this show and i've got some
decent expectations from it
it's only taken three slots but we now
have our first isakai of the batch
sukimichi
summoned to another world as a brave
warrior makoto misumi's adventure
doesn't start on the right foot i mean
he's apparently so
ugly that the goddess of the world
strips him of his title and banishes him
to the wilderness while he may be
lacking in attractiveness he has no
shortage of power something that he
wastes no time in exhibiting in his lone
journey standing against
everything that faith throws at him may
it be monsters or the gods themselves
it's time for the forsaken adventurer to
stand against
fate and prove his worth now i see a lot
of people being so stoked with this
finally getting an anime adaptation and
i can see
exactly why it's got a main character
that's way more overpowered than typical
isa guys it's got a lot of wild and
crazy stuff that i'm sure isakai lovers
would never get enough of this is a
really good year for isakai right we've
got all of these heavy hitters like
mushoku
tensei and spider coming out and now you
can add tsukimichi to that list
in the number seven slot is remake our
life
ah every once in a while we get a show
like this that hits a bit too close to
home hey
it does the job of being relatable so it
passes anyway remake our life tells the
story of kyoya
a game developer who's in his late 20s
having lost his job and starting to
regret his decisions
life throws him a bone as he wakes up
and discovers that he's travelled 10
years back in time to when he entered
college so how will this second chance
fare if you enjoyed something like new
game maybe this show can tickle your
fancy due to its similar themes
personally what i can take away from
this is that it reminds me of real life
but it's far more comedic in nature what
i'm liking more from this show based on
current expectations is how it's set to
be one of the relatively few anime
that tackle college life and its
intricacies comparatively speaking it's
a rarity to see connie's life being
depicted in anime and i think we'll get
a rather decent representation of it in
this anime i'll be expecting a lot of
laughs and some dilemmas that could be
relatable for the older audiences
[Music]
what do you know we have another
matsuoka harem coming up and both va
fans and isakai fans are waiting for
this to be fair this is a guy seems to
have a rather unique concept in
execution instead of a guy
dying and resurrecting in another world
you have a person dying and having his
memories and mind fusing with someone
else from the other world yep
it is a bit of a mouthful but think of
it along the lines of just his
consciousness that gets issac
so with that in mind our protagonist's
new host a guy named rio awakens to
brand new powers maybe this is the power
that rio would need to help him take the
next step away from the slums enrolling
in the royal academy after saving a
princess however being an orphan in a
school of rich nobles isn't quite the
most pleasant experience as rio would
soon learn personally me being a fan of
this specific genre and the light harem
action shows i'm definitely looking
forward to this one it seems to be
something that my alley and if you're up
for another one of these shows put this
title into your watch list the isakai
train just does not stop and we run our
way into the number five title on the
list
how a realist hero rebuilt the kingdom
himself in the plight of many anime
heroes in the modern era being
transported into another world there is
one problem though he's got nothing on
these overpowered forces of destruction
that call themselves underdog heroes
no no no for kazuya his idea of heroism
comes in a more
subtle way you see instead of going on a
quest to defeat some demon lord his idea
of making his contributions is to
rebuild the fledging economy of the
country that he finds himself in
apparently planted into a position of
power kazuya must gather his forces make
some arrangements and get his a game on
in the whole wheeling and dealing thing
with reforms to put the country back on
its feet now here's an issacai of a
slightly different flavor see this is
why the genre just refuses to die there
are just so many things you can do with
the other world concept and i feel like
a show like this is just touching the
tip of the huge iceberg of possibilities
this
is a show that i'm personally looking
forward to seeing
as we start breaching top three
territory we take our final pit stop
with
sunny boy
now with a title like that i really
didn't know what to expect at first it
turns out that the title is a show about
students drifting to another dimension
where they awaken their supernatural
abilities with their powers
their fight for survival in this
otherworldly dimension begins it's
survival in the sense that it's
structured more like an escape story
instead of a battle one talk about
another call isakai variant
the premise is pretty much similar to a
manga called drifting classroom
however for those who prefer a
comparison with more modern anime titles
i'm seeing something like
charlotte as far as the super power
students thing goes or maybe talentless
nana that's not exactly bad company to
be in now is it right mad house brings
us this anime original on july the 16th
the art looks gorgeous already and i
can't wait to see how the story's gonna
go overall i'm keeping my expectations
relatively high for this one number
three on our list is
peach boy riverside you remember the
show which had two yandere looking
characters as the main ones yeah
well it's coming this season and you
wouldn't expect something like that to
have the title
peach boy riverside now would you from
what we know of the show
it's basically an adventure story
featuring a princess and her savior
against monsters known as oni
it's the story of a fated meeting
leading to a journey that will affect
the fate of the world
now it sounds like a standard adventure
story but i assure you that it's not
that simple
from what i know it's a very enjoyable
show that bridges a lot of genres
it looks to be a really badass show that
has shades of momotaro
wait a second i guess that's where the
name comes from yeah overall peach boy
riverside
looks like a show that will have no
shortage of over-the-top action
and a handful of fan service oh and did
you know that it's by the same person
who did dragon maid
this one's gonna be good
our second most awaited show this summer
is the detective
is already dead with the title that
impactful you have to wonder what the
show's about
turns out it's the story of gimizuka
who's the assistant to one of the
greatest detectives ever
siesta or well used to be rather siesta
has been dead for a while now and
kimizuka has resigned himself to trying
to live life as an ordinary high
schooler that low profile life will come
crashing down when he stumbles upon a
girl who bears an uncanny resemblance to
siesta
only fate knows what it has in store for
the duo as they have their reunion from
what i can see this anime looks to be a
good combination of mystery and action
elements the novels have also got
stellar reviews
mostly praising the character work and
the fun interactions not to mention how
genre savvy the overall work is now i've
got my fingers crossed to see whether
all of that grey stuff will translate
well into the anime format
the case study of vanita seems to have
it all amazing art
a captivating soundtrack by yuki kajura
and a very interesting story about
vampires
all with the ever fitting backdrop of
europe in the industrialization era this
is where our story starts with young noe
going on a journey to find the book of
vanitas a grimoire that will supposedly
allow the legendary vampire vanitas to
one day take revenge
on his demonic brethren turns out the
story could be a bit
mistold after all the vanitas who noe
meets ends up being a completely
normal human doctor he does have a
specialization in vampires
but the grimoire we knew about is being
used to heal patients
perhaps there are more layers behind
this kind demeanor that we've yet to
know about
and it's up to no way to uncover those
who doesn't love a good mystery
especially one with a healthy blend of
supernatural action
from a production perspective few anime
this summer can probably match vanitas
as it is now
this is probably also my pick for the
big hit of the season
and i see this as something that could
appeal to both male and female audiences
as early as now
this is exactly why the case study of
vanitas is my pick for the number one
most
anticipated title of summer 2021 i don't
think it's gonna disappoint at
all as i wrap up this list
i wanna know which of these titles are
you looking forward to the most
i'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comment section down below if you
enjoyed the video
please leave a like and share this video
with your friends if you feel that you
want to take a step further and support
the channel
memberships and my patreon are available
avenues both come with perks and the
more supporters the channel gets the
better videos i can keep producing don't
forget to check out our sponsors game
moonlight sculptor links in the
description that's it for this video
hope you stay awesome until the next
time this is vinnie tube signing off
[Music]
you